James Harden stood up in front of a ton
of people in China and a ton of phones
recording him and called 76ers GM Daryl
Mori a liar and that he will never be a
part of an organization that Daryl Mori
is also part of and then he doubled
downed on it and repeated himself just
in case not everyone hurt him the first
time
[Music]
the 76ers didn't give hard in the
long-term Max contract he was looking
for so it was reported that Hardin and
the Sixers agreed to work on some type
of trade then it was reported that the
76ers ended all their trade talks and
they would bring Hardin back next season
24 hours later Hardin went public and
called Moria lie at this point we don't
know when this will all be resolved but
if Hardin doesn't report to training
camp for longer than 30 days the Sixers
can hold his contract rights and Harden
will lose his free agent status next
offseason